[Musique]
paris 23 heures des groupes de
noctambules se sont donné rendez-vous
dans le quartier des grands boulevards
pour l'ouverture d'une boîte de nuit pas
comme les autres très en vogue dans la
capitale et on ou provocateur le pipi
caca pour faire la fête
ils vont tous devoir descendre 10 mètres
sous terre d'accueil l'organisateur et
aladdin 33 ans
sa spécialité les soirées dans des lieux
insolites et interdit aux marchands
jours de janvier
je suis rendu compte qu'il y avait ces
deux axes et qui descendait sous terre
et pendant des années j'ai cru que
c'était en fait les sorties de secours
du métro et en regardant on sort du
compte il ya de la mosaïque mais j'ai
compris avec des pièces en dessous donc
en menant cette enquête on s'est rendu
compte qu'en fait c'étaient des
toilettes
classé monument historique des toilettes
classées et qui seront utilisés ce soir
par les fêtards
quelques mètres plus loin les mosaïques
d'origine bar podium et platine pour le
dj éclairage vestiaires il pourrait
s'agir d'une boîte de l'huile presque
normal mais il ya une différence avec
les autres clubs parisiens
pour accéder à ce nouveau temple de la
fête mieux vaut ne pas être
claustrophobe
les clients devront emprunter cet étroit
tunnel long de 50 mètres un accès
difficile et pour cause cette boîte de
nuit est illégal l'endroit appartient à
la mairie de paris
aladdin y est entré sans demander
l'autorisation
il y a huit mois depuis ils squattent le
lieu bien sûr sans payer ni le loyer
ennemis d'électricité
tous les câbles sont illégalement
raccordé à une co propriété voisine sans
se soucier des règles de sécurité au
niveau de la sécurité c'est pas pire que
certains autres plus à paris qui eux
sont légaux pour le coup on peut pas
investir 40000 euros dans la sécurité
pour être cernés dans ces moments
consacrés sens du hockey
il est presque minuit aladdin ouvre les
portes de son club clandestins sans se
cacher à quelques mètres de la police
combien de personnes sont attendues ce
soir ce soir
je pense 300 bonsoir à l'aise il
semblait donc en rien ma carte bleue
auquel aussi bon ok c'est maintenant et
sinon plus sortie définitive et 2 12
euros par personne
paiement en espèces uniquement pourquoi
aller d aladdin lui paye le dj un vigile
et les boissons qu'il revend si lever
300 clients comme il l'espère il
empochera un joli bénéfice là que marcy
plusieurs milliers d'euros
je me souviens quand tu descends 200
jeunes s'engouffrent dans le souterrain
un incendie ou un mouvement de foule
pourrait être dramatique
impossible d'évacuer rapidement autant
de monde mais les problèmes de sécurité
n'intéresse pas à cette jeunesse
parisienne branchée en quête de
renouveau
tu sais qu'ici c'est un lieu génial ah
ouais mais leur prison
inconscient ils prennent de gros risques
pour passer la soirée ici par le bouche
à oreille ce duo nos glandes est devenu
un rendez vous incontournable pour les
noctambules
[Musique]
et
le club d'al adha ouvre trois fois par
semaine et à chaque fois la piste de
danse est rempli
et
[Musique]
bravant la loi aladdin vont aussi de
l'alcool sans aucune autorisation
le bar est ce qui lui rapporte le plus
cauet par le bar australien son hamster
de promulguer une dizaine de fûts
barrière
[Musique]
et il n'y a pas de facture à rêves
attaque aussi
eh ben
aladin a le sourire ce soir son club a
attiré 400 personnes soit plus de 4000
euros de bénéfices en quelques heures
seulement
[Musique]
mais il sait que son business pourrait
s'arrêter du jour au lendemain
surtout si la police devait intervenir
si quelqu'un me demande eu ce
commentaire je répondrais sort hier de
voitures de flics
ce soir la police ne l'a pas remarqué
mais aladin sait pourtant qu'il est dans
le viseur de la justice
la mairie de paris réclame la fermeture
de sa boîte de nuit
un club sans destin qui incarne le
renouveau de la nuit parisienne dans le
centre de la capitale sur les grands
boulevards
nous avons rendez vous avec aladin dans
son club clandestins mais nous trouvons
portes closes la mairie de paris a
obtenu gain de cause
les anciennes toilettes publiques
transformées en boîte de nuit
clandestine sont fermés l'accès sous d
aladdin ne veut pas baisser les bras
il prépare sa riposte dans son quartier
général
il vit dans cet appartement de 80 mètres
carrés dans le centre de paris
tout comme sa boîte de nuit il s'agit
d'un squat à la main se revendique comme
un activiste anti système
je prépare de la colle pas ce qu'on va
avoir besoin pour pour coller des
affiches au sol face au conflit qui
l'oppose à la mairie aladin a eu une
idée s'est passé votre maison
une opération coup de poing pour sauver
sa boîte de nuit il va se meut notaire à
la grille d'entrée de son club en
diffusant son sit in sur les réseaux
sociaux
ils espèrent attirer l'oeil des médias
et obtenir une forte mobilisation de ses
partisans massés sur place je vais
dormir sur place
je sers aussi bien de la fin et soir
d'augmenter la pression jusqu'à ce que
la mairie régis à la réussite de
l'événement va pas mal reposer sur ma
capacité à tout dire sur place et à ne
pas parler pas céder pour compliquer la
tâche des forces de l'ordre qui voudront
le déloger son colocataire lui fabrique
un système identique à celui utilisé par
les activistes de greenpeace
il entre préparer ce tubes de pvc dans
laquelle on fait durer les mains pour
que les autorités ne puisse pas me
détacher magistrat l'intérieur accroché
derrière donc ils ne pourront pas
découper le tue parce que ce ne sont pas
sans les mains en médiatisant son action
aladdin espère que la mairie annulera sa
décision et qu'il pourra récupérer
l'espace qu'il s'est accaparé
illégalement à son arrivée plusieurs
habitués du clandestin sont déjà là pour
le soutenir
bah ouais ce qu'elle soit ce qu'elle
fait là bas dans la page soit aladin a
tout de même réussi à faire venir ce
journaliste d'un important quotidien
c'est parce que ça quoi
ça y est
je suis dedans la question c'est
pourquoi même temps une fois à l'abri
grâce à un passage dans la grille qu'un
de ses amis cadenassent aladin passe à
la deuxième étape le commissariat
il sait que sans opération des forces de
l'ordre
son sit-in n'aura aucune répercussion
alors il appelle lui-même la police en
se faisant passer pour un voisin c'est
pour prévenir que des personnes qui
essaie d'accéder au squat du 28
boulevard bonne nouvelle
comment ils ont interdiction d'accéder
aux lieux et là apparemment ce cas mais
les minutes passent et pas de policier à
l'horizon
après 7 heures d'attentes une patrouille
de quartier s'intéresse enfin aux jeunes
hommes
n'hésitez pas si vous avez des questions
je peux vous répondre ouais vous avez
l'air un peu perdu
c'est ce qui se passe pardon moi
pourquoi quelque chose d'illégal
on va prendre je vais pas vous dire on
est là en tant qu'élu pour la d'accord
très bien son effectif à battre et bien
manon obligés de dormir ici en fait
jusqu'à ce que la mairie nous donner une
réponse satisfaisante
pendant deux heures les policiers
tentent une négociation à l'amiable mais
aladin refuse de bouger
il sait que plus le temps passe plus les
chances sont grandes que la presse se
déplace
c'est du devin policiers et une dizaine
de véhicules de secours sont mobilisés
mais toujours un seul journaliste pour
le moment
les pompiers s'équipent pour faire
sauter la grille d'entrée
alors quelques amis d'aladdin tente de
s'interposer
on avait droit
[Musique]
tu
je
tibor de ballon des ventes stables
au final aladdin sera restée 12 heures
enchaîné à la porte de sa boîte de nuit
d'égal écoute on verra ce que ça va
donner mais je suis content que le jeune
homme est placé en garde à vue pour
trouble à l'ordre public
un seul article sera publié sur le coup
d'éclat d'aladin pas assez pour faire
reculer la mairie de paris
la boîte de nuit illégal est
définitivement fermée
mais al adha n'a pas dit son dernier mot
il compte très vite trouver un autre
endroit pour ouvrir un nouveau club plan
destin et il a déjà de bonnes pistes
il est deux heures du matin aladdin part
en expédition
[Musique]
serait ce parce que tu vois comment ça
va se passer mais on peut avoir la
visite des flics donc c'est tout
simplement se promener dans paris que ce
squatteurs expérimenté repère des lieux
inoccupés
non pas dans un bâtiment de la poste ont
forcément sur les hauts et des bas ces
mandats poste ya très souvent des
appartements vides
cette fois l'immeuble est habitée mais
il est sur une autre piste un peu
discret le bâtiment canada a repéré
appartient aussi à l'administration 500
mètres carrés en plein paris
anciennement des locaux de l'anpe qui
sont vides pourtant depuis plusieurs
années communes ont eu un peu
embarrassante du tout je pense c'est
pour ça qu'il n'a jamais été du coup
hier encore pour savoir si le lieu est
bien inoccupés aladdin va tenter une
opération périlleuse pénétrer dans les
locaux
en passant par le toit pas trouvé
d'accord
momo son bras droit le rejoint c'est un
spécialiste des ouvertures de squats
là en l'occurrence pour surya besoin de
kort
c'est assez rare voilà des gants d'être
un outil eux deux mais on se fait des
années qu'on fait ça depuis celle
escalade momo se lancent à mains nues
sur la gouttière sans fil est rentré
illégalement dans une propriété privée
est puni d'un an de prison
en moins de deux minutes momo parvient à
accéder au toit à 15 mètres du sol il
lui rentre intérieurement chasseurs 6 il
a pris sa review and security france
puis cela fait depuis dix ans aladin a
déjà ouvert une quinzaine de squat mais
ce soir tout ne se passe pas comme prévu
[Musique]
diallo ok on saura que te presse pas te
prépares d'accord
à tout bon capteur alarme dire ça la
larme du bâtiment visité par moments
retenti il est 4 heures du matin le
bruit risque d'ameuter les voisins et
surtout la police qui peut arriver à
tout moment
[Musique]
le génie rapplique échec pour aladin et
momo mais pas de quoi les décourager
ils savent qu'il faut en moyenne une
vingtaine de tentatives avant de trouver
un lieu qui réunit toutes les conditions
pour être squatté tu traînes escalade
[Musique]
leur quête se poursuit' une grande
partie de la nuit dans le nord de paris
au petit matin ce pilier de
périphériques attire l'attention
d'aladdin de savoir si ce lieu est
capable d'accueillir d'étape
derrière deux piliers se cache un local
une station de métro à une bretelle de
périphériques sont à 50 mètres seulement
un critère important pour aladin son
nouveau club clandestin doit être
facilement accessibles pour les fêtards
cet ancien garage de la mairie de paris
est abandonné depuis dix ans aladdin n'a
jamais squatter des espaces aussi vaste
j'ai calculé ça fait mille mètres carrés
c'est énorme c'est le doubs soit treize
fois publique aka il ya plein de choses
à faire ici on peut faire de la fête
c'est sûr y'a pas de voisins d'autres
coups ça créerait pas de nuisances
à la 20 vient juste de trouver un
nouveau lieu mais il pense déjà à la
soirée illégal qu'il veut aussi
organiser dans moins d'une semaine
[Musique]
dès le lendemain matin
aladdin et son équipe sont à pied
d'oeuvre pour transformer le local c'est
le début d'une course contre la montre
les squatteurs doivent rester discret
s'ils se font repérer par la police ils
peuvent se faire expulser sur le champ
mais une procédure judiciaire est
nécessaire largement suffisant pour
qu'aladin rentabilisant droit qu'il
s'est approprié
[Musique]
vous gérez les crises partons donc un
coup de chance
l'électricité n'a jamais été coupé le
compteur est vétuste mais quelques coups
de tournevis et le tour est joué
ramassez le gros médias tant dans la
poubelle et après tu as les stater pur
aspect toute la poussière
comment ça c'est le cas si en tout
aladin a mobilisé une dizaine d'amis et
de bénévoles acquis à sa cause
ils vont passer la journée à nettoyer
les mille mètres carrés du hangar dans
moins de cinq jours aladdin espère
accueillir ici plusieurs centaines de
fêtards aladin veut organiser sa
première soirée clandestine de plus vite
possible le squatteur imagine déjà
comment il va aménager sa nouvelle boîte
de nuit légal ici c'est la cuisine par
exemple on a pas mal de boulot la voyait
plus aucune réalisation c'est assez
craquera l'appareil très mauvaise et à
sa manière les toilettes
[Musique]
alors si à cette pièce il ya pas mal de
casiers parfait pour des vestiaires
alors là sera espace pour faire la fête
toute la superficie est parfaite
quelques jours plus tard les mille
mètres carrés sont métamorphosés prêt à
accueillir la première soirée d'aladdin
[Musique]
vraiment déguste dans moins d'une heure
aladdin ouvre pour la première fois les
portes de son nouveau club plan destin
ils organisent ce qu'on appelle un after
l'une fait à l'aube plus discrètes qu'en
pleine nuit et le squatteur a pris
d'autres précautions je vais balancer
l'adresse parce que les gens sont censés
arriver dans l'eure donc je pense qu'ils
sont en train de faim une partie sont
déjà en train de décoller pour venir ici
aucune leur foulard et pourquoi vous
dévoile et l'adresse au dernier moment
pour éviter que de la drees s'ébruiter
voilà pour imiter les premiers avec les
autorités grâce à une campagne sur les
réseaux sociaux
aladdin espère attirer plus de 500
fêtards comme on dit je suis donc ça
fait 360
dans quelques minutes les premiers
clients doivent arriver
pourtant tout n'est pas encore prêt
alors là c'est les toilettes improvisées
c'est assez compliqué de mettre en place
tout ça parce que c'est que du système d
n'est pas deux il ya pas de d'évacuation
d'eau aussi donc ça a été compliqué là
il est moins 10 et c'est toujours pas
prête
eh ben c'est pas grave les gens et se
tiendront pour glisser aladin a recruté
deux vigiles
peut-être que l'un de vous deux jerez
intérieur pour fouiller les sacs il
espère faire le plein mais le bouche à
oreille
or at il fonctionné la police va t'elle
gâché la soirée
quelques instants plus tard un premier
groupe arrive puis vers 6h30 du matin
des dizaines et des dizaines de fêtards
débarque aladin a choisi de faire son
after un dimanche matin pour récupérer
un maximum de jeunes qui sortent des
boîtes de nuit traditionnelle en
quelques minutes seulement sa nouvelle
boîte de nuit qu'on destine fait le
plein
parce qu'à paris sein même de je t'aime
c'est justement de vrais lions
réellement faire la fête sans quoi ce
truc noir mais c'est du béton partout
des capteurs partout
robin acv tout semblait se sent bien que
on n'est pas dans une boîte classique on
croirait dans un championnat est une
bourgeoise
je voulais aller par mes amis qui sont
sur des montres cabaye enfin canal après
à l'heure avec une ambiance de la peau
et des boutiques nous passons
aladin à ses recettes pour attirer le
maximum de monde
alcool cigarettes
ici aucune interdiction et les
consommations sont bien moins cher que
dans les discothèques classique
la pinte de bière est vendu 5 euros et
ça marche
grâce au match fut en fait le plein tout
est parti je peux dire est ce qu un seul
fut donc c'est un peu délicat
les super tôt je pense qu'on va remonter
de la d'alcool très large bande à une
pénurie qui risque de poser problème à
l'entrée des dizaines de noctambules
continuent d'affluer
la recette de la soirée dépasse toutes
les espérances d'aladin
[Musique]
le ticket d'entrée est à 10 euros par
personne
enfin termes d'entrées
en tout cas prouvé sa salle
mille
il soit 10000 euros de recettes nettes
d'impôt sans compter les bénéfices sur
la vente d'alcool
de quoi remplir les poches du squatteur
devenu chef d'entreprise et roi des
nuits clandestine à paris même s'il
assure que l'objectif de ces soirées
n'est pas lucratif mais enfin
c'est une satisfaction de voir tout le
monde
et qu'est ce que vous risquez en
organisant des soirées clandestines les
amendes
mandé
peut-être un peu de prison
mais bon on continue parce que ça a du
sens donc
les jamais motivé par le juste le
plaisir de voir les autres faire prendre
du plaisir et non il est 14 heures les
derniers fêtards de paris vont se
coucher
[Musique]
aladdin aura le temps de faire trois
soirées avant que la mairie de paris
l'ex pulse une fois de plus il est
reparti à la recherche d'un nouveau lieu
à squatter pour organiser ces fêtes
illégal
[Musique]